there's been a lot of controversy about
the sonic character when the first
trailer for this movie came out earlier
this year did you know this the internet
freaked out about the way that sonic
looks this is true people Sonic fans saw
his teeth they saw that he had teeth
they freaked out twitter was full of
negative reactions this is a real
reaction Sonic the Hedgehog's human
teeth is a good reminder that there is
truly no god people went nuts it got so
bad they had to delay this is all true
they had to delay the movie so they
could redesign Sonic so it's not to
anger the fans this is all true yeah
well now that the new trailer is out the
film's producers have been sending their
newly designed sonic on a kind of
goodwill tour and our show is one of his
first stops this is the new and improved
redesigned Sonic the Hedgehog let's get
him out here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello conan's yeah
hmm yeah about your new look sonic
pulled out all my teeth alright can you
please stop jumping around please I do
see the human teeth are gone is there
anything else about your new design you
might want to address sonic oh you're
right Conan I did forget something
pretty huge my fans
you know you people could have directed
your outrage at any number of in
justices around the world but you chose
to spend your time and energy
complaining about the design of an
animated movie character based on a
video game from the 90s so remember fans
everything you see here is all because
of you see the movies your time wasting
trolls
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all yours
I'm gonna have nightmares about his
hands no the other stuff